Hey T.Y. just calling to make sure everything's a-okay. Yeah Andrew, you called five minutes ago. I'm fine.
Wait, someone's coming for the AFC South. *gasp* But I was only hurt for three years!
Okay T.Y., go deep. The next part is very important. They're gonna take the division
AAH, I SEE TEXANS! 8 STRAIGHT WINS. THEY SAY THEY SAY THEY HAVE A NUKE! DESHAUN WATSON!
Oh golly! I don't know who you are. I don't know what you want. But I'm Andrew. Hello!
I have a very particular set of skills. Skills I've acquired over almost half a career.
Skills like accuracy, good decision-making, and recommending the perfect book!
Sorry for evading you. Good try though.  So close.
Skills that make me a nightmare for people like you and I'm sorry about that.
I need you to be focused, so we all play our best.
AAAH he's gonna torch our defense!
If you let the AFC South go now
That'll be the end of it. Oh boy. What kind of a person would hang out in a gross place like this? Oh hello
Mr. Irsay! Andrew man, I like you man! But if you don't, I will look for you,
I will find you, you silly goose now absolutely destroy you. Uhh I can't tell if he's threatening us or not
Hi Guys! You forget how mobile he is. Get him! I have cover now!
(Nelson Comes in) AHHHHHHHHHHHHH
Subscribe to the channel watch more episodes, I gotta go